more I think bricks to expose and we
touched on it was the fact that there
seems to be this schism between the
media gloss and the average working
person on the street man woman and how
actually more more people are becoming
less more and more disenfranchised with
the media yeah why do you think that I
think a lot of those is there is because
of the individuals who are working in
the media because you know I'm old
enough to remember when when I first
went into newspapers newspapers were not
full of public school boys and girls you
know it was it was it was a trait a lot
of people went into local newspapers
because their father was in it or
because you know it was quite a good
apprenticeship you could go and do a
journalism course when you were 16 you
could become a reporter indentured but I
say the local newspaper in Hastings or
in Cardiff or something like that and
they were just ordinary members of the
community and they didn't go and work in
the community they had covered the local
council meetings and then they sort of
move up to Fleet Street and all that
what we've got now it seems to me is
some very highly educated people who
have all been to Oxbridge at some point
or other and if not they've been they've
got a degree in something another you
know and they've all become part of this
same establishment it's a sort of
separate establishment to the
establishment but the media for me
should be anti-establishment you know
you shouldn't be part of it you
shouldn't be sitting there going oh I'd
really like to end up you know running a
quango I'd really love to end up in the
House of Lords for services to
journalism I'd rather be sticking two
fingers up to them you know I don't want
anything from them I want to hold them
to account and I don't think enough
people really do that and somehow
there's been this kind of cult of
personality where you'd look at people
like Paul Mason you know who's a great
example of someone who was meant to be
an economics journalist and I think he'd
worked nicely remember he was economics
correspondent for the Channel 4 News and
then he suddenly became his labor
activist and he come he go
well what is which one of these things
are you and actually at least you knew
what where he was coming from
he seems have gone completely mad you
know he's out with placards warning
about this and the other he's now left
have now turned on him for being not
left enough Paul Mason ya know because
apparently has been talking about
Kirsten Alma being the answer right all
the people that want Rebecca long Baily
to get the job or would were rather keen
on Jerry I think he's basically come out
against Corbin was the left of Starling
I know I
well something's gone wrong
but I think you know when you watch
people are Adam Bolton and you watch
people on Sky generally you know they're
very remaining you know whether they
think they are or not they absolutely
are you know and the news agenda that
they choose to follow tends to be very
much ruined by that and I think that's
the problem unlike you know genuinely
sort of people who try to be and I know
that people accuse me of being you know
a Tory and all of that but actually if
the Tories do something wrong I'll
criticize before I won't find reasons
not to I won't find another story to do
you know but there were so many cases
during the remained campaign and then
the leave campaign where after that
after the referendum you know I remember
the BBC doing a story about Northern
Ireland saying that basically all that
all the cattle would have to be
slaughtered you know if this congruent
went through with Boris Johnson and with
no backstop and they actually had to
apologize for it the next day because it
turned out to be complete enough to
nonsense the nfu came out and said that
when we're getting this from but it's
complete rubbish we will not have to
slaughter all the castle you know just
stuff like that your basic politics and
basic journalism getting it wrong like
that question time as well I mean you go
to question time and what she does is to
get into it you know necessarily can't
see any merit in it really at all and
they're so desperate to try the other
thing about balance I think I'd comment
but who said there's someone in America
who said you know balance is not about
giving equal time to absolutely everyone
because there are some right nothing's
out there you don't necessarily want to
equate one person's thought process with
another and so the person who said this
in America said you know if you're
trying to be balanced if somebody says
to you it's raining you know you don't
get somebody on who says it's raining
and somebody on your said it's not
rating you looking out the window and
you decide whether it's raining or not
and then you tell the people whether
it's raining you know you don't
necessarily take every single view and
just repeat it as if it's you know
gospel because we know that the people
who want to be in the media now we're on
the media very sophisticated now you
know people are very good at spinning
stuff and you think the media has hit
this point of crisis now you look at the
mainstream media and we I mean we were
talking you know the Sun declared and
record losses of 68 million pounds what
is the purpose of the mainstream media
do we need it anymore well I think
politically
speaking it's nowhere near as
influential as it used to be I mean I
was watching Prime Minister's Questions
the other week and having a conversation
with someone saying even even Parliament
is actually less relevant now in a way
than it used to be you know Prime
Minister's Questions is no longer what
it used to be you know the debates in
Parliament are no longer where they used
to be because you feel as though
everything is kind of already
preordained it's already stitched up you
know all the decisions are being made
now in Downing Street they're not really
going to Parliament to debate them they
now don't even have to because
everything's gonna be passed through I
think that's I don't I mean I can't
imagine any newspaper being responsible
for Boris Johnson getting that
incredible 80 seat majority I don't
think you could you could point to any
one columnist that was that was formerly
powerful you know I think as entities
they're still you know part of something
but they won't last forever in and I
think you guys doing what you do me
doing what I do in a smaller way perhaps
but also we're doing a lot of stuff on
YouTube now you know there's many more
people watching YouTube now have just
been turned off TV all together really
[Music]
you
[Music]